What can you see that's bad?
Just my look yeah
Hi, guys our name is Grace Helbig if you did not know, now you know, your life is different now
Father's day is upon us which means it's time for all that weird buried emotional sh*t to come
Smack the fan. father's day is this Sunday if you didn't remember you're welcome, and if you did remember
I'm sorry this is kind of bad way to intro this let me a hey
You know you win some [you] lose them said every dad when their child is born every [year]
give or take I try to make a video in which I give you some
Inspiration on creating gifts for your father for Father's day and this year is no exception except this is just basically a cooking video
That can be also packaged as a gift to your dad cooking bread [that's] beer and wieners in it. [it's] basically exactly how your mom got pregnant
Honestly, that's the only reason that this video is happening for that singular joke so worth it
I see a ton of recipes online and which you can make bread with beer
substituting the yeast and if I can substitute any food for an alcohol
I'm going to do that also this year for Father's day and likes to my dad or my stepdad that's watching this video
Stop watching right now. [okay]. You guys don't know how to use computers so you won't be watching this video
I got my dad a beer of the month Club
yearly subscription, I got my stepdad a
Steak of the month Club yearly subscription, so I thought that I would combine those two [things] in this potential Father's day meal
It's the Dad equivalent of an edible arrangement. We're making bread with beer and we're putting some wieners in it
I got to wash my hands and then take your shot of tequila because alcohol
Eliminates Bacteria, I'm using recipe called quick beer bread from Glittering Goulash.com
It's basically when I pinterest beer bread recipe. This is one of the most popular ones that came up
I'm going to use this recipe as like a
Foundation and then I'm going to modify it a little bit kind of how dads make their children
I'm going to make a child, but based on my persona
I'm going to modify the way it operates from the world with others cool. We have to preheat oven to 350
Degrees is the microphone on okay because I really want you to listen to me
Does my impression my dad okay generously grease a loaf pan?
we should wash this is what every hair makeup team says about me every time they have to do my hair and makeup for an
Event hey now. I just generously grease this loaf pan
[if] there's anyone that knows anything about a generous grease [it's] a girl from New [Jersey]. Let's do this
this is the way my mom taught me how to grease any baking pans when I was growing up you take a paper towel and
a bunch of butter grease and then you just like
Smear it in there, we've generously greased
We should get std check, but hey every jersey girl knows that ignorance is woohoo
We're going to get a bowl and add three cups of flour
Probably not clean if they stick together when you pick up only one 1/4 cup of granulated sugar beautiful a tablespoon of baking powder
That's what my dad thinks I sound like when I explain anything youtube related to him lol a teaspoon of salt
[I'm] just going to eyeball it
Now we whisk all of our dry ingredients together [in] for ten then we need a half stick of butter
Melted which doesn't necessarily work because I decided to try and go healthy and get [smart] [balance] [in] a tub
So it's not in stick form but you know what was in stick form [your] dad when he
You look like vanilla ice cream. Don't do this to me. Oh [you're] [super] melted, okay now
We're going to add oh I forgot an ingredient dohey a 12 ounce bottle or can of beer do cans come in 12 ounces. No one knows
I'm using Stella artois [why] because it's on my dad's favorite beers
I'm [too] I like to think that the name of this is actually someone with a speech impediment saying
stellar author which I am I have two books available if you did not know [just] some very casual
but you know
intimidatingly wonderful self help guys call grace's guide
The art oof pretending to be a grown-up and graces style the art of pretending you have it and oh my God
organic Transition
You can listen to these amazing self-help books that I've written
I team up with audible all the time as you know if you have watched my videos for a while if you haven't you're dead
To me, [but] hi
resurrected welcome back
I hope you continue to stay with us [all] involved is an amazing website for audiobooks both of my [audiobooks] are available on their website
As well as other books like I can't make this up : life lessons
Written and vocally narrated by Kevin hart wow we all know that the eyesight and good old dad is
getting bad
audible.com Slash Grace and he will be glad
or mad
But get your free audio [book] for yourself or your father with your free 30-day trial area audible.com slash Grace back to our [wiener] bread
Let's do this you [take] a 12 ounce bottle of beer put it into our dry [ingredients] and whisk it together
No, [dad] would be so embarrassed. No, why dad would be so embarassed
Okay
basketball
My dad's back on board. I just want to make sure this isn't poison
It's not poison. [I] mean it is poison okay?
This goes in this is acting as our yeast in our bread just
You know for science this seems incorrect, so we just mix this up. How do we do this?
Oh, we stir with a wooden spoon. Oh
Metal whisk is the opposite of a wooden spoon [this] was a purposeful joke not an accidental idiot moment wooden spoon
Stir this with a wooden spoon until it's just combined. We don't want to over combine it and you guys see that
I'm a cinematographer dad whoa this is actually like maybe bread, okay?
Oh, we need to get our melted butter now remember that friend
Pour half the melted butter into the greased loaf pan boom boom [then] we add our batter, okay?
So it feels a little off, it feels like batter in a soup of butter
And we're supposed to pour the other half of the melted butter on top, but hey
We did it bad choices are what led to all of us being alive?
So who am I to [judge] this recipe right now?
And this beer bread recipe says that we bake in the oven for 50 to 60 minutes, but before we do that
This is where my modifications come in and I'm going to add a couple of wieners [right] so put some hot wieners inside this bread loaf
That's what your dad said to your mom. [I] want them to be a surprise. I don't want to cut them putting them in full side
Hmm everyone thinks that they're going in full-size. Oh my brand deals are all gone. We're going to three now
We're putting our weiner bread into the oven for 50 [to] 60 minutes
Again didn't plan this correctly
that's your dad said when you get it wait, all my breads done. Loaf have finished
that's what your mom said the night
It looks like bread this is our loaf it looks slightly golden brown
But I feel like I might need to put it in for longer the other bread beer
Recipe that I read up on put this aged cheddar cheese carry [gold] on it. So I'm gonna put some cheese on top
What great dad doesn't [have] [a] layer of cheese to him this smells great
Is what no one ever said about their dad ever let's just shred this on top oh
this might be really good and I'm really nervous about doing well because I know I can't consistently maintain that no daddy issues there
[I] love my dad honestly genuinely
I put maybe too much cheese on this we're gonna put it back into the oven for a few more minutes
Just to see if it like I don't know I don't know I don't
Let our bread rest. Okay. The loaf is not hot anymore, is what your parents might say before you find out. They're getting a divorce
Ha let's try wait what am I calling this dad bread? No meat loaf no weiner loaf?
the Bread [weiner]
Cuz dads always want to be the breadwinner
[oh] my I might have made just one giant corn dog this
looks incredible
Let's taste it
Yeah, everything's good about this. Okay. It's a little gummy
Which is not an adjective you want to use for bread but it's really good
You know you might have needed to cook it more if you get tired swallowing a-oh But there you go we made a very very elegant
Father's day Snack we put some wieners [in] a hot cheesy loaf if you guys make this at home
Which I encourage you to do let [me] know by tagging me in
Photos on Instagram or on Twitter and Follow me on all my [social] media platforms and subscribe to this [YouTube] channel
Turn on the notifications. I make videos Monday Wednesday and Friday [now] [as] you know sometimes not days only and sometimes
Anyway, I don't know
..dominate hand.. [wow] no, okay?
This is why I don't do thumbnails well
God dang [it] my dad refused to buy me Barbie [dolls] growing up
And I really wanted Barbie dolls growing up because I was raised with all brothers
So just wanted some sort of feminine energy
So the only Barbie doll my dad ever bought for me with native American Barbie and she was beautiful
But [she] was on a pedestal you couldn't play with her so you just had to admire her from afar
I think that's why I'm the way I am today
People can't get close to me
Hahahaha, no one knows for sure the why, [haha]